Emmanuel Macron de retour sur le terrain
le chef de l'État est aujourd'hui à
Saintes en Charente-Maritime pour porter
son projet de réforme du lycée
professionnel c'est pas simplement une
réforme dont je suis venu parler
aujourd'hui sur laquelle nous
travaillons depuis maintenant un an avec
les ministres
direct pour moi c'est une cause
nationale le président a reçu un accueil
bruyant de la part des opposants à la
réforme des retraites tout à l'heure
nous ne sommes pas au rendez-vous de la
promesse que nous devons à ces élèves
c'est pas la faute des enseignants ni
les dirigeants de ces établissements
c'est pas la faute des entreprises c'est
le système lui-même qui est aujourd'hui
pardon de le dire comme ça mais mal
fichu quand vous dites il va au contact
des Français non plus avoir de contact
avec les Français parce que les
manifestations sont interdites il y a
des cordons de sécurité qui l'empêchent
d'avoir accès aux citoyens malgré
l'interdiction de manifester ils ont
organisé une casserole à proximité du
lycée que devait visiter le président de
la République un lycée qui a été victime
d'une coupure volontaire de courant à
l'intérieur du lycée pas de casserole
Emmanuel Macron avait un vrai fan club
l'électricité vient d'être coupée par la
CGT dans le lycée que Emmanuel Macron un
groupe électrogène prend le relais pour
que le chef de l'État puisse faire ses
annonces on va mettre un milliard
d'euros par an en plus sur le lycée
professionnel pour se donner les moyens
autour pour moi de trois objectifs
d'abord nous attaquer au décrochage je
disais on a un tiers de décrocheur donc
c'est la première bataille et à la
rémunération notamment des lycéens
stagiaires dès la rentrée prochaine
entre 50 et 100 euros par semaine moi je
suis prête on est beaucoup à être prêt à
l'embêter pendant quatre ans s'il faut
ah oui partout il ira il va pas pouvoir
bouger la une oreille moi je vous le dis
et il est pas question qu'on abandonne
comme ça même si les syndicats
abandonnent vous inquiétez pas on
abandonnera pas il est pas question de
faire des manifs à répétition pendant
six mois
c'était j'ai dû le dire il y a un mois
c'est ce que je veux je voulais dire par
là c'est que on ne ferait pas tant que
on concentrerait pas sur les retraites
une fois que la bataille serait
totalement finie je vous le dis la
bataille n'est pas finie aujourd'hui
nous nous avons un président autoritaire
dur qui se réfugie derrière la
Constitution qui effectivement a été
respectée et nous disons nous donc qu'il
va falloir aussi la changer cette en
revenir à la il faut pas faire croire
aux Français que ça il le ferait
simplement si on faisait des journées à
répétition il faut su il faut utiliser
tous les process tous les process tous
les tous les toutes les opportunités de
peser parce que il y a des événements
qui peuvent se passer ça menton oui il y
a un afflux de personnes migrantes et
notamment de mineurs parce que Madame
Meloni d'ailleurs le gouvernement
d'extrême droite choisi par les Amis de
Madame Le Pen est incapable de régler
les preuves migratoires sur lesquels
étaient élus torchon brûle entre Paris
et Rome le ministre italien des Affaires
étrangères Antonio tasjani annule sa
venue dans la capitale jeudi conséquence
de propos jugés inacceptable du ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin ça veut
dire que Madame Meloni c'est comme
Madame Le Pen c'est-à-dire que elle se
fait élire sur vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir et puisqu'on voit c'est
que ça s'arrête pas et que ça simplifie
je vous assure j'ai cru que c'était le
graphique c'est-à-dire que le fait
routage en France je sais pas pourquoi
il est au point mort et il y a quelqu'un
un petit homme gris si on mettait des
caténaires sur les autoroutes et qu'on
faisait mal rouler les camions mais même
vous vous riez mais je vous assure ce
pays est complètement fou en fait comme
chaque matin James March directeur d'une
école primaire aux États-Unis ouvre
cette benne à ordures mais surprise
un ours jaillit les 200 fuit chacun de
leur côté cette vidéo publiée sur le
compte Facebook de l'école est devenu
virale on va on va tous terminer dans un
hôpital psychiatrique
et attendez il y a je blague pas il y a
une expérimentation en Alsace qui est
prévu à la fin de l'année 2025
anniversaire la nuit pêche effectivement
ça a permis que nous arrivions en tête à
l'occasion des élections législatives je
le rappelle c'est trop souvent peu dit
que d'oublions le nombre de députés
quand même qu'il y avait dans
l'hémicycle on n'est pas toujours
d'accord sur tout mais c'est aussi la
force de tout collectif que de d'être
riche de ces divergences